I go to the supermarket I get two crusty  rolls from the ones they bake in in the  Market Deli counter I get quarter pound  of American quarter pound of Swiss  quarter pound of ham quarter pound of  turkey quarter pound of Bologna quarter  pound of salami if I was working quarter  quarter quarter yeah homie  I take all of those meats and I put them  out on a platter I sit in front of the  TV and I take and I just make these  monster sandwiches this is why you're  not married but dude you you put on you  put on your favorite old sitcom or  whatever you just let it play and you  eat until you're tired and then you lay  back and sleep this is not good you lay  back and you sleep  good you make another sandwich you're  trying to kill yourself  probably telling me